foreign
[Applause]
we usually left very early in the
morning we like to kind of beat the
morning crowds it usually took about you
know 45 minutes and uh
that was the same kind of route that we
took every day three times a day
so that morning in particular we were
walking and um and I saw a gentleman
that I had seen before in the past and
if you're from New York you know
that certain individuals you know
if you've seen them before in the park
you know to avoid and this was a
gentleman that we had seen before in the
park and avoided he would talk to
himself he always had very obvious
Tendencies to be a little bit seemingly
unhinged I just didn't make eye contact
and I was really just trying to avoid
him
uh he saw us and he started to
um try to interact with us and I had
moves to the further side of me to the
left
and um he reached into his bag and he
took out what was a gatorade bottle
filled with a liquid and I
you know again was just trying to kind
of assess the situation you know not
interact with him and he started
spraying it all over us and it was only
later that I realized it was a bottle of
ear and he had taken his stick and he
was
coming after us it was only when I was
halfway up the stairs and he hit me on
the lower back I don't think I was
really processing everything and when I
turned around moose was then trying to
protect me so moose was like on his
leash and he was kind of
interacting at that point and he hit him
straight across the face
and at that moment you know I just um
you know I just wanted to protect my dog
and my dog was trying to protect me so
it was a very difficult situation
it was an emergency vet and so you had
to kind of just handle your dog you know
you had to hand your pet off I did that
and then they called
pretty quickly and said that he was
septic
and it was not good
he was two and a half
so immediately a woman reached out to me
and said she had also filed a report
with the police and that she had had a
similar instance with the gentleman
she described him to a T and we
connected right away and then after that
I had an outpouring from the community
saying they knew exactly who it is he
was a figure in the park I mean I also
um
you know I had interacted with him not
interact with him I had seen him in the
park previously I knew exactly where he
slept so I reached out to the police
immediately and said
um this is where the gentleman lives
this is where he sleeps
um
please go just park a car
and uh just you know I I'm worried about
the community I filed the report
immediately after that I was given it to
people who were going to be on the case
and they both went on vacation for two
weeks
the police had made it very clear that I
needed to be present for him to be
apprehended I would have never ever ever
in my you know wildest dreams have ever
wanted to a go into the park and be
interact with him I had I wanted nothing
to do with any part of that
aspect of it
I I was furthest from anything I ever
wanted to do but at this point it had
gone on almost three months and I just
wanted him after multiple calls of him
being seen and you know the public
reaching out to me I just wanted it to
end
so I followed him he had like a little
bit of a cart and came after me with
mace the first person to arrive on the
scene was this Sergeant who came in from
Staten Island
so literally he left his home on Staten
Island he was the first person to
respond
you know this is a prime example
somebody who's known for being violent
it's it was an easy
it would be an easy resolution I gave
them exactly where he slept exactly
where he stayed he's been renowned and
renowned from like everybody in the
community it was never a question of
being able to find him
why it has come to this is a little bit
confounding
this shouldn't have had to come to this
and you know I shouldn't have had to be
attacked twice
um you know it's it was hard enough to
to reconcile moose
becoming a victim of this me becoming a
victim the second time is really hard to
reconcile
[Music]